this task force doesn't officially exist
which leaves us on our own two jerks and
costumes and a couple of rejects
it's like a real team out there
[Applause]
hi my name is aveda from gate culture in
singapore i hope you are both doing well
it's so nice to see you again
now james the opening title sequence had
me howling like never in my life did i
think i'll be seeing john cena dancing
any more than i already did in the
suicide squad so why is there so much
dancing in peacemaker
i think that you know peacemaker is uh
you know we see him dance a little bit
in the beginning you know he's joyful
but i think um
i don't want people to skip forward on
the credits that's all i want people to
watch i want people to see the names of
all the people that worked hard on this
show from you know production designer
to our editors you know fred and greg to
all these guys that worked their butts
off putting this show together i want
people to not skip over their names our
guest stars that we have at the in the
front end of the credits every every
episode i think that it's great for
people to see who uh who worked on the
show and so the skip forward button
is my enemy and i'll do whatever i can
to vanquish it and in this case i made a
dance sequence absolutely it was
absolutely entertaining and john are the
dance moves original did you get a
choreographer can you teach me one of
those dance moves the big dance number
is 100
um choreographed and that took a long
time to learn the uh the tidy whities
dance number is 100 interpretive and uh
experience for me so uh
i blacked out for a little bit i don't
even know what i did
[Laughter]
now the last time i spoke to you james
it was for the suicide squad and out of
all the characters that you debuted in
the movie and somewhat tried to kill
why was peacemaker the chosen one to
lead his own series the chosen one i
like that um
i think you know listen first of all i
loved working with john we had such a
great time working together in the
suicide squad
secondly we talked a lot about the back
you know the backgrounds of blood sport
and rat catcher 2 in polkadot man we saw
where they came from they all had a
great arc in the show where they all
changed and became something different
from the beginning of the movie from the
beginning peacemaker didn't have any of
that we didn't get to see where he came
from we didn't get to see a change in
him uh so i think that giving uh you
know i think he deserved that six
episodes to really see where he came
from where he's going how he got to be
the way he is and hopefully see some
changes in him along the way so john
looking at your acting resume you have
always played the good guy and that
changed when i saw you as jacob coretto
and peacemaker somewhat falls between
the good and the bad so what about him
made you want to take on the role and is
he a superhero or a supervillain to you
well man
certainly a chance to work with james uh
starting from the suicide squad and the
potential the absolute potential of
peacemaker if you are starting with the
a blank slate uh as as james would say
it hasn't it's not an ip that's been
overly mined we don't know a lot about
it so you kind of have the ability to
craft it and in that
in that crafting you can find what works
and what doesn't and i think that's
really really fun there's there's no
shoes to fill there's
you're the first one
to be able to portray that is peacemaker
here or a villain i think that's for
audiences to decide i think peacemaker
in his own eyes needs to see himself as
a hero to justify what he does
but i think uh audiences will decide if
peacemakers are here a little bit i like
that you said the audiences get to
decide because he wholeheartedly
believes that he's a superhero and for
me as a viewer when i saw him after
suicide squad i'm like yeah right you're
no hero you're not alone there and i i
really like that because that's what
creates
uh dynamic character and that's what
kara interesting conversation and and
entertaining viewing yeah and things
actually start to change like episode 4
onwards that for me was when i started
seeing him differently but now to both
of you what marks a good superhero i
think what mark's a good superhero at
least as far as movies and television go
is the same thing that marks any good
character i mean we need to believe in
that person as a human being we need to
believe that that's a real human being
and um
if we believe that somebody real who has
depth and layers then we'll go on that
journey with them and if we don't
believe that person is real with depth
and layers then we're gonna get bored
and we're gonna tune out so i don't know
if the rules for what makes a good
superhero is any different from any good
character in uh television or movies
yeah from a character's standpoint
100
heroism is virtuous super heroism would
be super virtuous someone who is super
virtuous but that that can get a little
one-dimensional i think maybe that's why
true great superheroes are often
characters that may not resonate with
the audience
a lot of superhero movies different
characters resonate with the audience
ancillary characters wrestling with the
audience
i think that's one of peacemaker's
strengths he's not
super virtuous so there's a there's a
lot of room to want to root for i think
if if peacemaker was
a true superhero he certainly wouldn't
be as entertaining thank you so much for
the time i had such a great time i hope
to see you again we will see you again
i'm sure
take care
[Music]